i'm tim ferriss author entrepreneur
angel investor and now tv host
i've spent my entire adult life asking
questions then scouring the globe to
find the answers
on this show i'll share the secrets of
pioneers who have faced their own fears
we'll dig into the hard times big
mistakes tough decisions and how they
got through it all
the goal isn't to be fearless the goal
is to learn to fear less
i'm calling for fearless i'm your host
tim ferriss and on this stage we'll be
deconstructing world-class performers to
uncover the specific tactics that
they've used to overcome doubt tackle
hard decisions and ultimately succeed so
imagine yourself all alone on stage in
front of 14 000 people staring directly
at you for many of us probably most of
us that'd be a complete nightmare but
for my guest tonight it's just another
day at the office the man you're about
to meet is one of the most prolific and
respected comedians in the world he's
done five hour long comedy specials
hosts one of the most popular podcasts
of all time and is the co-creator and
star of the animated series f is for
family please welcome to the stage
bill burr
[Applause]
[Music]
hey how are you
what's going on tim
how you doing buddy i'm good i'm good
[Music]
[Applause]
this uh this looks like a ted talk
like we're going to be out here talking
about artificial intelligence or
something we might this is really
creeping me out oh yes it's very sterile
all right i've wanted to sit down chat
with you for so long yeah we've been
texting trying to get it going yeah well
here we go and here we are
welcome to my home yeah and i thought a
fun place to start might be with
philadelphia so we have a video to show
and as context and feel free to correct
me and we can add more afterwards
but
at least some or all of the comedians
have been booed off stage up to that
plan no that's the uh that's the urban
myth that's your first guy got booed
okay and um the lineup was killer and we
were just playing these outdoor like
amphitheaters so it was like you know
kind of made for music and uh
and we got down to philly and um i don't
know they were all wearing like eagle
jerseys and tailgating and throwing the
football it just seemed like they were
ready for a playoff game and it was
still light out
and there's something about jokes they
don't work when there's lights on like
it has to be seedy and that so not only
was it was like daylight it was sunlight
and uh half the people were still out in
the parking lot and there was like just
like maybe like 2 000 people just
milling around walking around so he
basically got thrown to the dogs but
what happened is they booed him off
stage and it kind of set the tone but
then you know everybody was kind of
doing their thing i mean it was crazy it
was like patrice o'neill tracy morgan
ralphie may bob saget i mean uh bobby
kelly jim norton da mairera i mean it
was just murderers row
so but you could just feel like there
was something um people were surviving
and i saw a few people who always went
long went short that night i'm not going
to say who but one who always burned the
light and it wasn't patrice it was
somebody else i mean he was literally
mid-joke and just stopped and said it
was you guys were great good night god
bless and walked off and that's when i
started thinking like uh oh it's like if
that dude who always goes long just
pulled up he's supposed to do 20 minutes
i don't think he did i don't think he
did 14
and at that point i didn't want to do
the show
and i wasn't nervous at all i just kept
thinking like i could have just been in
a funny bone in front of 40 people who
gave a [ __ ] and wanted to come to the
show
and so then i wasn't nervous at all and
then i knew i was probably looking back
i probably knew i was in trouble because
i wasn't nervous and i went out there
and i was like oh [ __ ]
and
i did my first joke which i didn't
realize they were playing in the
advertising on the radio so everyone
already heard it and nobody
nobody laughed
and i was like literally i was like
already neck deep and it was so long ago
and then i just remember i went to
another joke and i just bailed halfway
through i was like you guys aren't gonna
laugh at that and then they booed and um
let's maybe we should roll the tape i
don't want to see this
i think you guys want to see it
[Applause]
[ __ ] rocky is your hero the whole
pride
[Applause]
infested [ __ ] shoulders
and your awful man tank top seven
minutes left
[Applause]
six minutes left and i will be selling
my cd after this [ __ ]
[Applause]
minute left in the period
[Applause]
this doesn't change anything this set i
still [ __ ] hate you people
you guys all gonna go see rocky 19. oh
dude i think you can win
listen i'm out of time
i've never seen that are you serious
i've never seen that enough really no
so did you decide to do the countdown
before you went out i mean is that
something you no no no what happened was
luckily i had been booed before
so it wasn't a new thing so the first
time you get booed is a you know it's a
hell of an experience because you have
what you want but it's the exact
opposite emotion you have the entire
crowd's focus
except there's no love it's just hate
so the first time that happens it's
really uh i didn't know what to do but i
i also i remember just afterwards
thinking about it going like why didn't
i let that fat guy boom me i let that
chick with the weird glasses like why
didn't i say something
i just remember thinking i was just mad
at myself going like all right you got
booed you know they didn't think you
were funny
uh but you sat there you know it was a
variety show they had like a
contortionist and somebody with a snake
and then somebody's saying saying like
pour some sugar on me and one of these
leather pants and then they'd bring a
comedian out it was just it was a
complete [ __ ] show
so
i just remember afterwards i just
remember being like upset at myself that
i that i i was like dude you could at
least throw one punch you should have
done that but but but then i didn't
think of it again i didn't think of it
again because uh you know you don't plan
on something like that happening so i
don't know why i did that i just started
doing it and that they had the clock was
there and i was just looking at it and i
i just i don't know i think in that
moment i decided i wasn't going to leave
so i think the countdown was kind of for
me like you're doing cardio you know
that and you're like i'm not going to
look for one song you know and then look
all right another three minutes went up
so here's the funny thing so we still
had one more date on that tour something
was telling me don't do the last one and
then i went to cleveland
and it was like as i walked out on stage
everybody booed because they wanted me
to trash their city
so then it became these things like i
can't do this again or then this is my
act this is like gallagher smashing the
watermelons i got to come out and read
about all your sports teams and [ __ ] so
that was the one i freaked out about
because i thought it was like i thought
my career was over i was like everywhere
i go i'm going to get booed and blah
blah blah i'm glad that people enjoyed
it because i was definitely i was
embarrassed that the whole thing
happened you grew up in mass correct
what was your childhood like growing up
in massachusetts i was sort of like you
know this shy kid i had like orange hair
i mean i was just like i was a mark the
second i walked in the room everyone was
on me like every one time i think it was
my birthday my mother got me this my
parents got me like this little cowboy
outfit i was like four years old you had
like the hat there was a little vest and
then i had like like the belt with the
guns and it's supposed to be like the
mother of pearl handles but it was like
plastic so she sends me all i even had
like the little bandanna she tied it
around and she just sent me outside and
i don't even think i made it to the end
of my driveway and like these big kids
came by and they just took the guns out
of my holster and just smashed them on
the ground
and i sat there looking i just was like
crying
they laughed and just walked away and
then i picked them up and i walked
home and walked back into the house my
mother was like who did that who did
that i was like big kids
and she's like
i can't remember she just like made me a
sandwich and that was kind of it
but it wasn't like a big deal back then
i remember you would just do [ __ ] in the
neighborhoods and parents just watched
they just figured out what you did i
mean we threw rocks in this kid's pool
and before i even got home my mother
already knew what happened and uh there
was a lot of that stuff going like they
were building new homes
and you'd go down there and you would
steal [ __ ] for to make a tree for it or
you just
vandalize them for no reason when did
comedy enter the picture for you i
always made i always got kids to laugh
and i moved around a little bit when i
was a kid and just making kids laugh was
a way to get people to stop beating the
[ __ ] out of me um
or bigger kids you know wailing on you
or whatever so that's how i would make
friends i would just i would just make
people laugh and i remember making
people laugh in the in the uh in the
classroom you know i get
that made you feel good you know made
the pretty girls care about who you were
hopefully you know it was just an
attention thing i guess which people
influenced you when you're a kid i mean
are there particular comedians that you
gravitated towards or memorized or
anything like that i watched all this my
all the stuff my dad used to watch all
the things that they now sell on tv all
the uh
all those dean martin rose foster brooks
i loved uh
remember bob hope my dad would always
laugh and i never got the jokes
there was always some obscure references
and then as i started to get older uh
cheech and chong and i remember um
buying richard pryor's album not even
though who he was i just knew
he looked funny i'm not going to say the
name of the album but it's the one when
he's like that's got the n-word in it um
george carlin yeah i just started buying
him i remember buying the eddie murphy
record when he had the rose in his ear i
bought that just because he was a black
guy and i knew that richard pryor was
funny and i was just a little white kid
going like well this black guy was black
guys are funny can i just like i just
bought it and i had no idea who he was
did you memorize any of their bits or
how did you yeah this is how out of
touch i was with what i wanted to do and
i used to do my paper route and i would
be uh doing the bits
i missed eddie murphy's got hit by a car
bit i would be doing that out loud to
myself as i was riding through the snow
where pretending i was in front of the
school doing it and everyone was
laughing thinking i was great but it
still didn't dawn on me at that moment
that maybe i wanted to be a comedian i
don't know why it just it just seems
i think for kids today that's hard to
understand because they can just shoot
something instagram or whatever the
whatever the hell they do
youtube it
on the internet whatever the hell it is
and um but back then it was a zillion
miles away it was a zillion miles away
like it did like
even like thinking about becoming a
comedian i thought you had to like move
to hollywood
to do it like i had no idea um
yeah there was like three channels you
had no idea in high school what do you
think you were going to be when you grew
up do you have
any idea
no i was failing miserably but like i
did great in school i did great in
school and right until it counted i did
great right up to eighth grade and when
i in my freshman year i was going in i
was like i'm gonna go to notre dame and
i'm gonna become a lawyer and by like
sophomore years it's like i'm going to
be a construction worker and go to
wentworth
i'll drive a truck um
yeah i just i don't know i think
somewhere along the line i just wanted
to have a fun job i wanted to have a fun
job i did know that because uh
you know i i hated everything else i
didn't like carpeted areas i didn't like
wearing suits like i liked working in
warehousing
i liked i liked having a job where i
could walk or walk away from an area i
always just remember seeing people who
had to sit in cubicles like they just
had to be there
and if you're not there and immediately
they know that you know you're screwing
around like you know where is he he's
supposed to be right here he's not
getting what he's supposed to be done so
if you work in warehousing you could be
on like a forklift or unloading a truck
or cutting up boxes or just doing
something
as long as you were in this giant area
they were all right with it and um like
warehousing is great it's all class
clowns musicians
like
addicts alcoholics and [ __ ]
i remember this dude yeah i remember
this dude coming into work he came in
like three hours late it was like 90
degrees out and his hair was soaking wet
from a shower like dripping down he's
like oh yeah the traffic the traffic was
was brutal
just like dude your hair's still wet
from the shower and i remember um
yeah he had a major coke problem
and uh yeah he'd be why i remember my
boss had a coke problem i remember
getting that job and the first day i saw
him he was this guy was like probably
six four and couldn't have weighed more
than a buck 60. he was just just wired
and they had this pallet jack that was
like electronic
and they're like yeah let me take you
over to meet the boss and he saw me and
he was just so just geeked out he was
just like driving it towards the dock
back and forth going i'm going to drive
it off the dock and just coming back and
like lifting his look at his lips and
[ __ ] and i was just like all right this
is going to be my boss
and i i
i worked the third shift and it was all
people like me working our way through
college like if you know if you didn't
get student loans or whatever i got laid
off from that [ __ ] because there was
this this fat [ __ ] used to come out
from the uh he was fat and he was a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so
he would come walking out
he come walking i mean he's wearing
short sleeve dress shirts and you know
those guys so fat he had to really swing
the arms to get out
he just come walking out and he look
around and all these bad ass dudes all
of a sudden would be grabbing boxes and
pretending to work and i just had that
thing maybe it's the stand-up comic
thing where that that that thing you
just like i was like you know what [ __ ]
this guy
[ __ ] this guy and i just look at him
like hey what's going on like i'm not
i'm not doing this little [ __ ] i'm
working out here i don't want to [ __ ]
extra work when you come out here [ __ ]
you
why don't you pick this up your tub of
[ __ ] that's what i was thinking
so then
i ended up uh
right after that moment like an idiot i
then asked the other the coked up guy
for a raise and
and then i think the fatty was just like
the hell with this guy so then i got
laid off from that
and um
then i was collecting unemployment which
i had never done and i felt real i felt
like a piece of [ __ ] doing it because my
parents worked so hard and uh it was a
bad economic time and i couldn't get a
job and i just decided
that i wanted to be a comedian because
working in the warehouse i was working
with this guy who was hilarious and he
wanted to be a comedian
and he was the first guy that said it he
said you know one of these nights i'm
going to uh
take a shot of jack daniels
and just go on stage
and then and all of a sudden it wasn't
on tv once again you know we didn't have
youtube so it was sitting next to me i
was thinking well if he can do it i can
do it
so um
i knew that i was a baby step kind of
guy so i had rather than just doing it i
transferred to emerson which was more of
a performance school so
and then i just went there and i just
every class i could get up in front of
the class i would do it no matter how
nervous i was and i was a really shy
withdrawn really withdrawn kid
and um
i just forced myself to do that and
every time i did it even if it didn't go
well i felt good that i did it and then
i started to like it and
i started doing radio
because radio was a good baby step
between performing and being funny to
like a live crowd because it was like i
was on a microphone there was an
audience but i couldn't see him i
couldn't hear him and i remember i did
this shift 2 a.m to 6 a.m on 6 40 a.m
wecb and all it did was broadcast to the
dorms nobody was up nobody was listening
if they were they were listening to a
better radio station and i just remember
and i'd always be i'd always be on like
the thing going like you know whatever
there's some that was dinosaur junior if
you have any requests give me a call no
one ever called and finally i just said
jesus i go somebody just call in tell me
you hate me i don't care and then the
phone lit up
and i picked it up and this guy goes i
hate you
and then hung up and i just remember
just being like in a total panic i was i
was mortified
and then he called back and he
apologized said hey he goes my
girlfriend's working the next shift i
just happened to be listening she told
me to call back and apologize but like i
felt like such a nerd and um
which i was i was a nerd i commuted to
school i didn't know anybody i just
walked in with my stupid book bag and i
would do the things whatever and then i
would just go home and i would go to
work like i kind of had a job once i had
my paper route in third grade
i had a job
ever since i've been working so did you
have any particular at that time i don't
have to remember but
when you were shy how did you was there
any particular milestone point do you
remember when that changed when you
became more comfortable
um no it just slowly got better but i
don't i still in certain situations i am
sort of it's weird because what i do but
i am also a very like
i'm one of those guys like the second
the show is over if nobody knew who i
was that would be that is that is the
ultimate that would be perfect like
before the show i need you to know who i
am so you buy tickets
you know or else i would be screwed but
the second it's over like i don't need
it to keep going do you remember your
first
open mic gig
getting on stage yeah what was it
walking i signed up for a a talent
contest at emerson because i made a new
year's res resolution in 1992. this is
how scared and shy i was about doing
this i was like i made a new year's
resolution that at some point
in the calendar year of 1992 i was gonna
go on stage i gave myself a year to do
it and i was gonna do it
and and then that was it my baby stepped
way into it um because i knew if i said
i'm doing it next week i'd go into a
panic
and i might not ever do it so
i said that january 1st and literally
three weeks later the emersonian
newspaper they said uh nick's comedy
stop
was having a uh a talent contest find
boston's funniest college student which
was just this total scam to pack it with
college kids watching their drunk friend
go up there and bomb and then they make
all this money i remember it was a
contest and i didn't on any level try to
win it my whole goal was just having the
balls of when they called my name to
walk up there and start talking that's
all it was i remember sitting down
trying to write material and it's just
like and i'd been funny my whole life
but then all of a sudden to sit down and
like
sort of artificially create the moment
where it's like if you and i are hanging
out socially and you say something it's
like you don't even think and then you
just sort of and then i say that and
blah blah blah but now it's like with
the stand-up i have to create that
moment
bring the crowd in
to the world create that moment and then
say it and i had no idea how to do it
so
i remember i can't even what i wrote i
basically i had some sort of ideas and i
went up there and i remember taking the
mic and it was the only time i've ever
felt having an auto body experience
where i thought i was watching myself
was probably this panic thing where
you know the emotional me just left me
like we don't want to be i don't want to
go on this ride let's see what happens
so i remember taking the mic out i still
remember what the mic looked like
and this guy billy martin was hosting it
was now like this big shot on bill
maher's show i just went i completely
forgot what i was gonna do
and i just started talking and i i went
into the middle
of what i was gonna do then i went to
the beginning and then to the end it was
like a tarantino movie you know like
with travolta walking by in the
background in the diner scene it was
kind of like that but i sort of was able
to do all right and i think i only did
like three minutes i was supposed to do
five and i got off stage and i didn't i
didn't care about anything and i
remember
that was it i was like this is what i'm
doing and i tried construction i was in
warehousing i tried sales
i i remember i got a health insurance
license i even passed the test i got
certified to take x-rays i was working
in a dental office i did all of this
[ __ ] and none of it like none of it like
i didn't care about any of it and this
is the thing i just did it i was just
like that's it this is what i'm doing
with the rest of my life but that night
after i did it even though somebody else
won i didn't care i just remember
driving home in my truck
listening to motley crue kickstart my
heart oh great song yep
and uh
just literally screaming
that was so psyched that i did it now
and i was only like i was middle of the
pack i was nowhere near even remotely
the funniest person
what was it about that experience that
made it click for you one of those one
of those things in life that you don't
have to think about
it just it was what it was right it was
awesome and i was just like why wouldn't
i want to do this like my first thought
was like i'm doing that for the rest of
my life then i did my next show was at
this comedy club stitches
and that one went okay and then my third
show that was my first what's called a
hell room
which yeah it's not a doesn't sound good
yeah it's not a comedy club it was a bar
the people there were eating they had no
idea there was going to be a show
they turned off the bruins game and then
they bring you up and uh that was my
first time experiencing
a crowd watching a show that didn't want
to see a show
and uh
i just remember i remember doing my
first joke my first joke that really
just got nothing and feeling
that punch in the chest
of something bombing and then having to
regroup and i had nothing to regroup
with
and i remember i bombed so bad i got
halfway through my time and this guy
jack lynch was the host and i said on
the microphone i said jack i'm bailing
i'm bailing and i got off and i was so
embarrassed i didn't want to walk past
the crowd or the comedians and i sat
down in the first empty chair and i just
sat there like this scolded child for
like two hours waiting for the show to
go and and i wanted to leave but i was
so embarrassed i just sat there
it was horrible and i just remember and
then what sucked back then was there was
so much time between your shows oh yeah
you know there was like weeks between
shows so if you had a good show you
could ride the high of that but if you
bombed that was one of those things like
i got this thing like when i when i
embarrass myself for some reason it
comes out to me like when i'm in the
shower and i have to like shout the
memory out you know like i'll be in the
shower and i just think about it i just
be like ah i just like make these noises
just these
noises of like humiliation like oh god i
did that or i said that
i still do that in the my car like i'll
think of [ __ ] that i just did or
something i did 10 years ago and it's
this thing i'm just like because i don't
want to think it
and you know there's a self-loathing
about it that you know that i never i
kind of never got past those teenage
years of that oh god i'm such an idiot
like i never i kind of never got past
that i mean i knew i was gonna bond it's
inevitable it's like if you fight if you
fight long enough somebody's going to
come along a little faster and you're
going to get caught and it's like it's
still telling jokes it's it's it's
inevitable it's going to happen
and um
then it's just something you have to get
good at you have to get good at bombing
yeah and um
i had enough experience of doing it you
know that eventually you get good at it
then it doesn't it doesn't hurt you
anymore and is it just exposure is it
like getting a flu shot every season
it's just about the number of
repetitions you can just exercise
yourself to it yeah you just keep doing
it and and um
you know bombing is there's something
hilarious about it there's something
like if you but what the turning point
for me with bombing was was seeing how
funny was being able i remember one time
just being on stage and i was bombing
and i just pictured all my friends
watching me laughing at me in in the in
the back and then that got me to laugh
at myself and then i just started
thinking how much can i get these people
to hate me and i just left my act and i
just started trying to annoy them
and i didn't get them back they still
hated me but i had such a good time
i was like wow what was that that was
that was this new area of up that you
know i i didn't know existed the the
clean and not so clean kind of before
and after bilbo i find really
fascinating so we actually have a video
that this shows the contrast a little
bit i love my dad man he's hilarious
he's such an emotional guy you know i
know my dad was his funniest so was
whenever you like broke something
because my dad my dad would totally flip
out right but the words he used he would
actually thought it was a good thing you
know i mean like he'd break a window
he'd be like
nice real nice
oh that's beautiful
that is just beautiful
hey why don't you break them off
dude there was an epidemic of gold
digging [ __ ] in this country
and every night i put on the news
and i'm waiting for someone to address
it
[Applause]
every night never see it you know and
every night i bring up gold digging
[ __ ] and the whole crowd pulls back
like i'm up here talking about bigfoot
right
like i'm saying the moon's made out of
cheese or something
talking about [ __ ] people they're
everywhere
how many
how many more great men are going to get
chopped in half
before we do something
[Laughter]
why is it so quiet in here
[Applause]
god damn i don't get it
so when did you go to opening up to more
of i'm not gonna say profanity just
being yourself maybe
failing by just failing just trying to
do what they that i thought they wanted
whatever they were responding to and um
then that just morphed into well
if i'm gonna fail
i'll fail doing what i want to do in
this business
and then that led to me starting to
succeed
and
once i started to succeed doing what i
wanted to do
um my view of the business changed
where i then looked at it rather than
like it's this thing i'm running towards
it was like no i'm in it so this i just
look at the the business like it's a
giant mall
and i have a little store right probably
like those ones that are in the middle
that you walk by not that sure yeah a
little kiosk
and i just i have what i do this is what
i do you come in right this is what i do
okay if you want to buy something great
if you don't you know you keep going but
this this is what i do
and rather than i used to view it like
oh they're selling shirts i should sell
shirts and i got to sell candles and i
got to you know do nails and have like
this one-stop
walmart thing
and it's just like that just didn't work
for me i just i do a podcast i tell
jokes i act when they let me you know
because i have to audition space you
know but then i also just found with um
you know the people i grew up didn't
talk like that the stories i had to tell
people weren't like that very volatile
and they used colorful language as they
say and um there is this thing
with comedy purists where they're act
like okay if you work clean
um
you know then that's pure comedy that's
that's real comedy because you didn't
say any bad words but
you know which i do understand because
you can definitely use uh curse words to
to
you know
sort of steroid up your stuff but i've
also find what you know when people say
they want somebody to work clean it
doesn't just mean
don't say any bad words it also means
don't have any opinions
that will make people uncomfortable
because i could i could easily work
totally clean and there's groups of
people that you could completely
piss off and wouldn't want to pay you
just by your opinions on things so um
i just felt like it was a limited thing
and i've always liked
the rawness of um
with everything with music with film
with comedy of just going off
more um
the realness of that rather than this
totally polished thing which i had to
completely have an appreciation for
but the amount of times i've heard
comedians go like say something so funny
in the green room
and be like yeah but that's
like dude you got to do it on the stage
you got to do it on stage like nah man
that's not me that's not me it's like it
is you you just [ __ ] said it whatever
you're doing up there that's not you
that's you on stage and that's what
happens with comedy is like there's this
big like mystery thing about you got to
find your voice and oh is this who i am
is that who i am and i have this theory
that you walk in
with it
as an open mic and then you go on stage
and the weirdness of looking at people
and talking you become this is me on
stage oh i'm holding a microphone and
just becomes weird
it becomes weird and then you spend i
don't 8 10 12 15 years trying to get
back to
who you were when you walked in who was
this guy who was making people laugh in
the bars because like you just walked
into a bar and something happened and
then you're just riffing on it
but you you were cut you were
comfortable
then you go on stage and it's just like
oh [ __ ] everybody's looking at me and i
have to handle all of this uh what am i
doing with my hand how do i get this out
of the stand and it just becomes this
whole
you know just looking at yourself and
then then that who you are goes right
out the [ __ ] window
a lot of folks consider
the comedian's comedian right i mean a
lot of comedians look up to you and
they're like oh bill burke can
not only talk about anything he's
willing to talk about anything but he'll
this is self-employed
you can't get you can't get too into
this business yeah if you get too into
this business then you're [ __ ] and
then you become that guy you mean just
having contracts and relationships with
people no you get in business with
people but that's not your only thing
like i'll i'll never stop doing stand-up
and i have my podcast so i can and i
don't live a lifestyle beyond those i
live way behind those
so no matter whatever happens whatever
[ __ ] slap on the wrist i'm ever gonna
get from the the social media i'm still
gonna be fine it's when you um
you know it's when you just go into this
business if you're just an actor on a
show or you just host something or or
whatever it is
that like all of a sudden like if you
just did this you didn't have your
podcast or any other way to make money
if all of a sudden
you know there's some [ __ ] rumblings
if the people above you go you have to
go out there and apologize
you're in a situation of like or else i
can become homeless yeah so then you
have to go out there and even if you're
not sorry you have to say you're sorry
and i think that that's uh
that doesn't look like a fun thing
because i've seen people going out there
squirming yeah trying to like how do i
apologize without apologizing
to the 40 drunk soccer moms who all
tweeted at the exact same moment so this
became a thing
for eight seconds yesterday that i now
have to address so haven't said that if
i'm an [ __ ] i will say sorry but i'll
say it to the person
yeah you know yeah
like i don't get
i don't get this whole thing where
somebody secretly videotapes you at a
comedy club and then they upload it on
the internet and then you have to now
apologize to people who weren't at the
show
yeah it's like you weren't at the show
and you decided to what so why don't you
get mad at the kid who [ __ ] filmed it
like
that's it i am guilty of being a
comedian in a comedy club that tried out
a joke that didn't work
right yeah i don't know it makes sense
to me in my head everything makes sense
so the podcast uh so your podcast was a
very early influence for me i love your
podcast and uh
i see you've gone past me oh well
that's a cute one yeah you got there
freckles now look at it
[Applause]
well i think there's there's one thing
that arguably you do better than anybody
else and i'm sure it's one of many but i
want to listen to some of your ad spots
so we're going to pull up some audio of
a couple of your sponsor reads and i
think uh i think we'll pull up sherry's
berries first
this might be my favorite name of
anything i've ever advertised here uh
other than one white charlie's uh
sherry's berries for my listeners
double the berries
for just ten dollars more here's the
only way to get
this special 1999 sherry's berries offer
call 866 fruit
i'm sorry
what the [ __ ] am i selling
did i approve this this is [ __ ]
ridiculous
who the [ __ ] is gonna buy this [ __ ] this
is the funny [ __ ]
in my [ __ ] life
call 866 fruit everybody
oh punch truck
oh please spell out the words oh by all
means berries b-e-r-r-i-e-s
berries click on the microphone in the
top right corner and type in burr hey
you [ __ ] better buy some sherry's
berries because i'm going to get in
trouble for that [ __ ] read and i'm
not changing it because that was
hilarious
[Laughter]
when did did you do that from the very
beginning with with the host reads uh
did you start kind of taking the piss
out of sponsors from the very get-go
with the podcast because you were really
i mean early early pioneer this is 2007
or so i mean it was early this is
way back in the day so you were one of
the first kind of long-form guys
did you have standard sponsored reads
for a while and then
well i did it for years without doing
sponsorship so when i started doing
reads it felt weird to be this guy just
saying whatever i was thinking and being
funny and all that to all of a sudden be
like you know the chrysler cordoba blah
blah blah blah it just felt weird and i
was just like
people are going to have the ability to
just fast forward through this and skip
it
so i didn't feel like the comedy should
stop and um so i always you know i'll
just throw in a boston accent i'll just
do something to get them to listen
and with the sherry's berries thing that
i did
um i i hadn't read the copy and it was
so like
homophobic yet homoerotic the whole
thing it just was so ridiculous to me
like i couldn't believe it was true so i
legitimately started laughing and i
remember they were calling us saying
take it down take it down and i was just
like yeah tell him he didn't get to me
like i'm
i'm not taking it down that's hilarious
and i don't give a [ __ ]
because i got all this other stuff you
know once again one of those moments i'm
self-employed so you know i don't need
some chocolate-covered strawberry people
to pay my rent
i didn't put myself in that position
which i very easily could have i didn't
so i said i'm not taking it down but
what they learned because they're a cool
company
what ended up happening was people
ordered this stuff because i said i was
going to get in trouble and then it
turned out evidently they were delicious
and they sold a bunch more so what ended
up happening was was companies that were
younger and kind of understood it's like
oh this guy's he's making fun of us and
he's singing songs and he's cursing and
all this type of stuff but people are
listening and they're buying this stuff
so it kind of became one of those but
there's been others that haven't
had this sense of humor like i remember
uh nature box
came out and i for some reason was
reading it as nature's box
and
ed
and i was you know and i was like joking
around i'm like oh you're gonna go down
on mother nature right just just [ __ ]
around
but i also think it was just it was this
weird sort of stupid thing where they
were gonna like bring you a banana at
like three in the afternoon it's like i
can't [ __ ] do this by myself like i
need you to like if they are really
stupid i i will say it
and um because i just look at the
podcast whatever money i make often is
just gravy anyways like i can live off
my standup money you know and i mean
like i said i i
lived well within my means because i
i've been in debt and i didn't like the
way it felt i just would be waking up at
night going i owe these people this
[ __ ] money how am i going to get out
of this my car's breaking down that's
going to be more
and
so i've avoided that stuff i know a lot
of comedians have trouble going to tv
developing tv shows how did you find
your way to
efforts for family i don't know all my
live-action stuff that i wanted to do
and all live action means is just
this regular people everything that i
wanted to do that i really wanted to do
they would just be like oh that's like
you know that's sexist that's homophobic
this is what this is going to say to
kids this is mean to dogs and
they just would de-ball the whole thing
and then it would suck oh yeah i did i
did a pilot they shot it down and then
like two weeks later they're like hey
you want to do another show with us and
i said yes and it was with another
comedian and then we did it and we we
all got together and we were just like
hey
let's just give them exactly what they
want let's just do exactly what they
want and we did that and they still shot
it down and then that was it that was it
i just went off the reservation i was
just like [ __ ] trying to develop a tv
show i'm not doing it all right i'm just
gonna be a comedian that sells tickets
hopefully and if that's all i am who
gives a [ __ ] i'm telling jokes for a
living i'm killing it um
that was it i didn't have any ideas and
then one day i opened for this comic uh
steve byrne and he knew vince vaughn and
the guys at wild west and vince was in
the crowd he liked what i did so i took
a general meeting with them and they
were like so do you got any ideas for tv
shows i was like no
no i got none
i'm all out of them no they never
[ __ ] work nobody ever picks them up
i'm just sick of it there's always like
i'm always pitching to a woman they
always say women don't run the business
i haven't got to that [ __ ] level
and this i'm always going in just
pitching and there's always some woman
there going like i don't think that
can't get a [ __ ] power
hey what if the guy's a complete [ __ ]
[ __ ] and doesn't know how to dress
himself but his wife does oh that i like
that's a good one
yeah
so
just because you have a vagina doesn't
mean you can't be you know in the wrong
sometimes
so anyway so then i just i was on my way
out of the meeting they were just like
you know what else what are
you don't have any ideas i was like look
i know you guys are doing movies with
vince i'll play some a waiter in the
background i'd love to do something with
you but no i got nothing so and as i was
walking out i remember uh peter billy's
sort of walking me out i was like well
you know i do kind of have this idea
this cartoon idea or whatever and he's
like oh we want to do an animated show
let's sit down and it basically stemmed
from my childhood stories that i told on
stage
as a young comic and everybody got it
but as i became the older comic and this
new generation came up that had play
dates and helicopter parents and they
wore helmets when they rode bicycles
like they were in a [ __ ] race or
something
um
they didn't laugh at the jokes they
started beco everything was labeled like
oh that's bullying that's you know
that's mental abuse physical abuse and i
would literally be standing on stage
going guys this is funny this happened
to me
my mother was right i was telling all
these stories like so anyways i just
stopped telling the stories on stage and
then one day i was walking my dog i
thought what if i just made animated
shorts on my website i could do that
that would be cool i could ramp it up
and it'd be animated kids and no one
would give a [ __ ] and uh but of course i
never did it but then when i ran into
them and they're just this force of
nature then they ended up hooking me up
with uh the great mike price from the
simpsons who's done like 300 plus
episodes over there so
and um we came up we've just fleshed out
those little i was just gonna do little
stories like you know we go to get a
christmas tree or somebody buys a new
bike they turned it into this whole
world
we helped develop this whole thing and
then
we pitched the cartoon and i think they
were just like this is a weird choice
for a comic in 2010 but they just saw
that's vince vaughn all right we'll give
you six bill's a little [ __ ] christ he
falls apart if you just look at him all
right he's got no spine you gotta rub
his back during war movies he's scared
of everything gee i wonder where he got
that from susan what do you mean he gets
it from me ah you cuddle up too much and
you know it you know i work hard to keep
this family happy i keep everyone
everyone from killing each other well
today i would actually welcome it
do that again
i hate you
you take my socks off
oh yeah touch it yeah you like that yeah
you like that yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
very family-oriented show so and i got a
feeling you're going to ask me what
everybody asked me which is did that
ever happen
you know i was just going to leave it
open and just say anything any comments
no that's like
that show is like loosely based on all
of our childhoods so it's it's it's an
amalgam
it's an amount hey he showed it i didn't
make it
it's an amalgam
of like all our dads like i wanted like
my family to be able to watch this and
not be like mortified like i have a big
respect for the fact that i decided
to put myself out there and especially
it gets weirder every year with
technology and everything so like i
didn't want them to watch it like this
elements of the show right that my dad
would be like all right like i'll put
you through that [ __ ] wall he used
that was his catchphrase i put you
through that [ __ ] wall he used to say
that right he never did it he just you
know it's just an empty threat you know
but um but you know the other stuff is
like writer room stuff like that was
just like okay what if what if you know
they start having sex and it just it
seemed like they had this big huge fight
and he says this mean stuff about his
son and he doesn't know he's there and
it's just like well how do we get out of
this comedically how do we defuse this
what if they have sex so it's that that
aspect of it was like a like a writer's
room thing who drew the balls they're
very photorealistic i actually
[Applause]
i actually met the woman who drew it i
was doing a gig in um ottawa canada
big jump is the animator up there and uh
i i just happened when i had the gig to
come over and meet them i just happened
to be in town and they were animating
that scene and she literally had like
sketched three different ball bags that
she they looked like little speed bags
that she was gonna make and just so you
guys know you were mentioning bombing
and then just turning it into an
opportunity to vent being like i'm not
sure what that was but that was fun i
enjoyed that so i was talking to the
team about whether to use this video or
not i was like at least i can say i had
a pair of animated balls
that i forced an audience to watch
swinging around so you're welcome there
you go
so i thought we could we have a lot of
questions from the audience so i thought
we would we would throw it over the
audience get to those and we have some
in studio we also have some from the
internet
who have been uh kind enough to chime in
as well so the first one's from facebook
this is joseph swam so
effectively how do you generate ideas
and what is your process do you still
write stuff down
what are the sort of key components of
of where you start when you're
developing well i used to write it all
out and then i i don't write it now i
just
i just treat it like how i used to treat
like if something funny had happened at
work if i was gonna go tell my friends i
wouldn't write it all out memorize it
rehearse it in front of a mirror i would
just go up
and i would just tell them the story and
i would act out all the characters and
all that the way i did but what happens
is when you go on stage is like you know
you know it just you know you can bomb
you can have a bad show there's all that
self-conscious stuff so
um
i guess the process was trying to become
as comfortable as i was in a bar
shooting this [ __ ] with my friends
being that comfortable on stage that
took a while long time what are the sort
of key components of
where you start when you're developing
when you're starting uh meaning where
you start with say if you were gonna if
you're starting right now to do a
special
well usually it's just i'm walking
around i see something or i hear
something that'll get me going but if
i'm in a writer's block which is a big
thing for a comic how to get out of it
i find is i try something new or i'll
just i'll be at an airport and i'll j
i'll grab a magazine that i would never
read i'll grab like cosmo i'm just going
to get a different point of view because
your brain can get bored and when it
gets bored it goes into autopilot and
then you just stop seeing [ __ ] and um
yeah i'll just do stuff like that and i
also when i'm building a new hour i take
all rules of hack like this is hacky
material i'll do an oj joke i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm just going on stage just
anything just to be saying something new
something different and that'll
eventually lead into something um that's
worthy of of of keeping but i i
definitely write on stage but if
something happens
like i'll just
usually just make a mental note but
sometimes i'll just write down
like a word i'll just write down like
ipad
you know or or you know whatever boots
or something i just but i know what that
means like if something i know that
means something like you know somebody
stepped on my foot that day and blah
blah blah blah and that's the cue yeah
and so and then i just sort of write on
stage
writing on stage meaning
you are taking notes as you go through
yeah people say right on stage what it
really means is you just go up and just
wing it you just the same way you would
like i said earlier you come home if
something funny if you saw a car
accident you you'd come home and just
tell the person you're with you wouldn't
have to write it all down so um i've
done stand-up long enough where i'm
comfortable enough to do it and all the
great people that i see them all the
great men and women that i see doing
stand up today most of them do it that
way but some people want to do a little
bit of that a little bit of writing it's
but
i would say for that person is you got
to find what works for you
um just kind of be open to all of it and
then as you through trial and error just
sort of streamline it into your your
so-called process so if you met let's
say 25 year old 20 year old you can pick
the age who you seem you seem to think
had some promise as as a comic and they
wanted to be a stand-up comic
and they they had the same commitment
that you did at one point which was at
some point in the next year i'm gonna
get up there on stage and
do a set i guess there are two two
questions
how would you assess if someone could
stand a chance and then how would you
train that person i mean or or have them
practice um i don't you know what's
weird i can watch somebody young and and
everyone's like you'll just see somebody
be like that person if they do
everything they need to do could be
great at this and it's like a uh
it's a uniqueness it's just something
they'll say or something they do or
something the way they handle a
situation
you just see it's like it's like being
you know like an nfl scout you just see
them you know make a throw or something
like that's an nfl arm right there we'll
see if uh
if if he or she develops it or whatever
but um
i i don't i would never tell somebody
what to do because like uh how my brain
works everybody's unique so
what i would do though is go out of my
way to encourage that person like if i
saw somebody young and they they were
funny i would go out of my way
to make sure
that i said that because
they need that i i realize you know
you got to do that so this is from anna
clara ortoni her question begins with
some people just don't have a sense of
humor and how do you relate to or deal
with these types of people and i'll just
leave it general like that so whether
it's you get trapped with them at a
cocktail party or
in general crowd whatever it might be oh
cocktail party i would just walk away
yeah um if i'm doing stand-up yeah oh
man i shouldn't this is another one that
i i probably should this is some inside
[ __ ] all right
this is what i would do when there would
be somebody like you're killing
everybody and there was just that one
person that's just sitting there and
they're not laughing and they're not
laughing and they used to always bug
like that bug's a comic you're just like
they couldn't [ __ ] get that one
person it would ruin their night like
you'd let him i started realizing how
stupid that was i was like if i was a
president and this was my approval
rating i would be [ __ ] killing it
so i finally decided i'm going to have
fun with this person so what i would do
is like you can't see the people who are
doing it in the back it was the people
who were up front yeah so they would be
like right there and they're just like
you could feel the energy so what i
would start to do would i would over
commit to my jokes
act even sillier and i would send all of
them right out over their head and the
best thing would be if they were close
in the front row i would be standing
right up on them and my favorite thing
to do would be make some sweeping
gesture like over their head like i
would literally be like and my dad says
to me and i'm just totally just living
my dream like right in their face right
over him and it would just drive him up
the [ __ ] wall and then i would keep
throwing in like god you guys are great
i am having such a great time up here
and it was all that was the show within
the show for that one [ __ ] [ __ ]
and
like i learned all of these these those
types of things through years of doing
it through basically am i going to take
this as a negative or a positive and
realizing i i have the power to decide
like i can let this guy ruin my night or
let this woman ruin my night or i can i
can have fun with this
um it's the same thing like if you ever
do like the late show and only like
eight people showed up
i made the mistake of coming out with
eight people energy
and it sucked and then one night i was
just like you know what [ __ ] this i'm
gonna go out and just try to kill these
eight people enough that they bring
eight more and then i went out with this
positive thing and then i i that so got
ingrained into my work ethic like the
other day i had a buddy of mine who's on
his way up going like he was going out
dude he goes you know the old club
normally just told me that we only got
34 people
on the late show tonight i literally
felt like this jolt going through me
like just being like [ __ ] destroy
them [ __ ] destroy them and make them
bring 34 more because if you're not the
guy which i wasn't i was never the the
whatever the [ __ ] they were looking for
that's the only way to do it you just
kind of hack your way through
so we we saw you battling philly
in the beginning
and uh you ended up at one point at
madison square garden and i mean there
are only a handful of modern comics
who can play that venue or have played
that venue what was that like can you
walk us through what that experience is
unbelievable yeah it was awesome and uh
what i ended up doing
look at that
that was and i
i had um
i enjoyed every single second of it
every every single second i i made sure
on that one and i um because you got to
rent that thing out okay which is not
cheap so most of the money you make that
night goes right out the window so i was
like well i rented it for the day right
they're like yeah so i'm a big led
zeppelin fan
and you know they shot song remains the
same there
and that's also where uh robert plant
said does anybody remember laughter
which was the name of the show so
i rented a drum kit and some amps and
all that had made a bunch of my friends
came down and in an empty madison square
garden
we just jammed and played all this
cockrock from the 80s and some you know
uh yeah all that all that [ __ ] that we
used to listen to all the hair metal
stuff
um some black sabbath guns and roses
motley crew we just had the best time
and it kind of and like what was cool
was the union guys setting up the chairs
i was like is this going to bug them
they're like no they're used to bands
rehearsing and stuff and they kind of i
could say had an appreciation that we
had an appreciation for what it was and
they ended up putting us up on the the
screen they did the lights in the end
and uh now i had everything my agent
played guitar and i got him up there and
uh all these comments came down uh josh
adamer's ben bailey and all these guys
we just had the greatest time but what
was cool was it took away the scariness
of doing that place and it we just kind
of came in there and got our stink on it
for a little bit and then i remember i
went home
um went to the apartment and uh my wife
was there and i was waiting for her to
get ready
and i was drinking a beer
she's going drink a beer you never drink
a beer you never knew i said don't worry
about this one don't worry about i just
knew it was awesome
it was awesome
what did you think when you were on
stage when you were finally up on stage
well the best thing was joe derosa for
paul version joe derosa opened for me
and joe wore like this old lady like
looking knitted sweater
and sometimes one of your friends just
dresses in such a certain way you're
like willing the crowd to heckle them
which you usually don't you usually
rooting for the comic and nobody heckled
them so it like annoyed me
so when i went on stage i was like yeah
keep it going for version how about joe
derosa and his [ __ ] golden girls
sweatshirt and everybody started
laughing and i just stood there [ __ ]
on him for like 10 minutes and then i
just felt like i was in a comedy club
and um no i just knew i knew and i was
like they i had 90 minutes and i did 90.
i did the whole i was like i'm doing the
whole
thing i'm totally taking this in i
recorded and i'm only going to put it
out on vinyl because there's too much
overlap between that material in my next
special so it's just it's just something
who for total nerd of whatever i do and
uh
it was like
yeah it was awesome i never talked [ __ ]
about
you know i killed but i i [ __ ] killed
that night i definitely that was that
was a good one yep
if you could have any
billboard you wanted non-advertisement
but just a message you want to get out
to the world
what would you put on it
the first thing you fan did was go [ __ ]
yourself go find yourself kidding i'm
kidding i'm kidding um
[Applause]
uh maybe i would
i just i just have uh no it isn't no it
isn't no it isn't
i like it no so much people don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
and they're just so so much time
getting you into this [ __ ] panic and
then this is going to happen
and just read that no no it is
you got to be fine
even if you're not going to be fine
isn't it better to just exist thinking
you're going to be fine until it's not
fine and then when it's not fine then
you can just [ __ ] handle it then but
there's no sense to ruin right now right
ladies and gentlemen
thank you
thank you very
thanks for much
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you